When people tell me that money doesn't
buy happiness, I always say, "Yeah,
there might be some truth to that, but
surely crying in a Ferrari hurts a
little less." And honestly, I just like
the chance to find out for myself. But
what if I had a billion dollars? Would I
still be the remarkably humble person
that I am? Or would I become the kind of
person who looks at warehouse workers
needing bathroom breaks and thinking,
"That's an efficiency problem."? This
got me thinking, what does a huge amount
of money actually do to a person? For
instance, right now if I get a parking
ticket, I'm annoyed for the rest of the
day. I'll make sure to check the parking
meter next time. But if that same ticket
is less than a rounding error in my bank
account, do I ever check the parking
meter again? What does extreme wealth
actually do to someone's behavior? Does
it make you happy? Does it change how
you think? Can it physically rewire your
brain? And is there a point where money
stops being money and starts being
something else entirely? Before we go
any further, this video is not a
commentary on whether extreme wealth
should exist or who deserves what. We're
purely looking at what large amounts of
money and power do to the human brain.
The science is more interesting than the
politics. So, let's do that. A few weeks
ago, for the first time in recorded
history, one person crossed a trillion
dollars in net worth. A trillion. A one
with 12 zeros. A number so large that if
you spend a million dollars a day, it
would take you roughly 2,700
years to get through it. Which makes the
basic question more interesting than
it's ever been before. Does money make
you happy? Yeah, up to a point. Below a
certain income, money is all you can
think about. Not because you're greedy,
but because financial stress is one of
the most psychologically damaging forces
the human brain can experience. It takes
up head space. It keeps you up at night,
and it literally narrows your thinking.
As income rises, that stress disappears.
You can pay for your rent, you can eat,
you can stop doing mental arithmetic
every time you have to buy groceries.
That's not luxury, that's just a removal
of suffering. And when the suffering
goes down, happiness goes up. Go a bit
higher and life gets genuinely
comfortable. Options, security, the kind
of buffer that means an unexpected bill
doesn't ruin your month. Research
broadly agrees that this phase is where
money and happiness track each other
most closely. Go higher still and now
you're wealthy. Nice house, good
holidays, you'll buy a sports car and
it's great. But it still just gets you
from point A to point B and after a
while it just becomes a car. The jump in
happiness from having no car to having a
car was bigger than the jump from a car
to a Porsche. The gains are still there,
but they're flattening. And then there's
a level above that where something
shifts. Not just in how you feel, it's
in how you treat the people around you.
Because there's wealthy and then there's
billionaires. A millionaire buys a nice
house and a Lambo. A billionaire buys
influence, politicians, media,
infrastructures, entire industries. They
don't purchase things, they purchase
leverage. And just so we're clear on the
gap that we're discussing, the
difference between a millionaire and a
billionaire is roughly a billion
dollars, which sounds obvious, but
really sit with that for a second. A
million seconds is about 11 days. A
billion seconds is 31 years. The jump
from one to the other isn't a step up.
It's a completely different category of
existence. And somewhere on that
journey, somewhere between the Lambo and
buying a Senate seat, something starts
to change. And it's not just how you
spend, it's how you see the people
around you. Paul Piff, a psychologist at
UC Berkeley, has spent years studying
how wealth changes behavior. His
findings are not flattering. In one
experiment, participants were left alone
with a jar of candy. They were told
explicitly that the candy was for
children in a nearby lab. Wealthy
participants took twice as much as lower
income participants. The candy meant for
children. Twice as much. In a separate
study, observers watched intersections
and recorded which cars failed to to to
pedestrians at crosswalks. Drivers of
expensive cars were three to four times
more likely to cut off pedestrians than
drivers of cheaper vehicles.
Then there's the Monopoly study. Piff
ran a rigged version of a game across
over 100 pairs of strangers. One player
started with twice the money and got
paid twice as much for passing go and
rolled with two dices instead of one.
This wealthy player won every time. But
when asked afterwards on why they won,
knowing full well the game had been
rigged in their favor from the start,
they consistently said they deserved it,
that they'd played better. The wealth,
even fake, even clearly unearned, had
already changed how they saw themselves
relative to others. Piff summarized it
with a simple image. Picture a ladder
with wealth at the top. The higher you
climb, the more entitlement and
self-interest go up and the more
compassion and empathy go down. Every
step in both directions simultaneously.
The behavior is real and consistent, but
the question nobody had answered yet was
where it comes from, whether it's a
choice or something's happening much
deeper than that. This is where
Sukhvinder Obhi comes in. He is a
neuroscientist at McMaster University in
Canada and what he found using brain
imaging and neural stimulation is one of
the more uncomfortable things I've come
across researching this subject. Your
brain has a system called the mirror
neuron system that fires when you
observe other people. When you watch
someone stub their toe, part of your
brain simulates the experience and you
cringe. When you see someone smile, your
own facial muscles subtly respond. This
system is the neurological basis of
empathy. It's how you feel what other
people feel. Obhi found that when people
are given a sense of power, even in a
lab, even just by writing about a time
when they had control over someone else,
the activity in this mirroring system
drops, measurably and significantly. The
brain, under the influence of power,
becomes less able to simulate the
experience of others. And this is a
neurological shift that happens to most
people when they gain power. More power,
the more pronounced the effect. A 2025
study published in Molecular Psychiatry
went further. Scanning over 35,000
people's brains, researchers found
measurable differences in the physical
structure of the brain in people at
higher income levels. Specifically in
the regions that control communication,
empathy, and decision-making. Not just
reduced activity, structural
differences. The brain physically
changed. So, yeah, extreme wealth can
physically rewire your brain. And the
most uncomfortable part, the shift is
gradual, invisible. By the time it's
happened, you've no reference point for
what you've lost. You wouldn't even know
it was there. And here's how that
invisibility plays out in practice.
Money functions as a feedback mechanism.
It tells you when you've done something
wrong, when something costs too much, or
when a risk isn't worth taking. That's
the parking meter. That's the ticket I'm
annoyed about for the rest of the day.
In Finland, speeding tickets are
calculated as a percentage of your
income. The logic is simple. A fixed
fine means something very different to
different people. $200 to someone
earning 2,000 a month is a meaningful
consequence. It stings. You remember it,
and you check the parking meter next
time. Now, imagine you have a billion
dollars. That same $200 ticket
represents 0.00002%
of your wealth. Less than the interest
you earned while reading that sentence.
The feedback loop breaks. And when
consequences stop feeling real, behavior
changes. Quietly, gradually, without
announcement. You don't decide to stop
caring about the parking meter. You just
stop noticing it. At a certain point, a
fine that would devastate most people,
wipe out years of savings, even change
the course of someone's life, registers
as a rounding error. Not even a speed
bump, just the cost of a Tuesday. And
that's probably the answer to the
question from the intro. The point where
money stops being money is in the
trillion. It's the moment the figurative
parking meter stops mattering. And for
most people in that category, that
happens long before they even hit a
billion. And this is where the research
of Piff and Obie meet. The drivers
cutting off pedestrians aren't thinking
about cutting off pedestrians. The
monopoly winners aren't thinking about
the rigged game. The mirror neuron
activity is already lower. The feedback
loop is already broken. The whole thing
runs on its own, below the level of
conscious awareness. Which brings us to
the trillion-dollar question. What does
that actually feel like? Probably not
the way you'd imagine. The first person
in history to cross that number didn't
wake up one day and decide to stop
caring about other people. The research
shows the process is gradual, invisible,
and largely outside conscious control. A
slow drift driven by decades inside a
bubble where consequences stop being
real. To answer what a trillion dollars
feels like is probably nothing. Not
nothing as in empty. Nothing as in the
number has stopped meaning anything. The
parking meter, the fine, the
consequence, all gone. What's left isn't
happiness or unhappiness, it's just
scale. The first trillionaire isn't a
villain. The research doesn't care about
the person. It cares about what someone
at that level of wealth tells us about
the human brain. He's a data point, the
most extreme one we've ever had. And
what the data says is this. The brain is
shaped by its environment. And no
environment is more distorting for a
human than one where nothing, not
consequences, not other people, not the
parking meter register anymore. Money
buys happiness up to a point. After
that, it buys something else entirely.
And what it quietly costs along the way
might be more interesting than anything
it can purchase.